but what are your thoughts on the whole
just the whole [ __ ] man like with covin
and and and and the vaccine and all that
um
right wing america and black america
just are the two biggest
groups that don't trust the government
i don't know why right wing america
doesn't you know because everything's
been good the government does so much
good
i would like to believe so i understand
our concern you know
it ain't necessarily like it's been made
that you want to help us live right so
it's always that confusion and um
they just did a a bad job with handling
it and i can't knock them because i'm
not saying i would have did a better one
it did just kind of happen
fast nobody was playing
so you you're making a thousand
adjustments on the swing and it was just
so much misinformation the whole time it
was just like bad decisions like you
close down everybody's businesses but
then you open walmart which don't make
sense in theory you should have closed
down walmart and open all the small
businesses and allow minimum people so
it's always these questions and that
bothered people i'm saying don't nobody
black think america want them to live
that's fair and then everybody is like
well you know
it's the same people taking them but
[ __ ] they can manipulate [ __ ] for dna we
still got special things about our
anatomy that make us special so it's
always those questions